a lot of these reporters they didn't
talk to normal working class middle
class African-Americans polls
consistently showed even in the
immediate aftermath of the George Floyd
killing that something like 70 or 80
percent of African Americans in this
country in the United States want
current levels or higher levels of
policing that's consistent among polls
no one wants police brutality and people
support reform but this idea of
abolishing the police defunding the
police it came from an extreme Elite in
America and then it kind of filtered
down through the median activist class
it never represented the actual opinions
of normal Americans